[Music]
welcome back
so we're talking about vector calculus
namely the gradient divergence and curl
operators
and how we can use those to derive
partial differential equations
and encapsulate kind of physics into
equations
so i want to start today by really just
zooming into these operations of div
grad and curl
and in particular this all starts with
this
kind of dell or
nabla operator depends on how old
fashion you want to get
this kind of greek delta
symbol i guess a upside down delta
so del or nabla
and this is literally defined as a
kind of vector of partial derivatives
so we're going to think about taking the
derivative of something
as an operator or an operation and so
if you want you could put a little arrow
over this sometimes i do sometimes i
don't i'll do it right now
but if i drop this arrow it always means
the same thing this del or nabla
operator
these are the same word for two words
for the same thing
and this is literally let's say we have
a three dimensional
del operator this is going to be
a partial partial x in the i direction
plus partial partial
y in the j direction plus
in the k direction we're going to have
partial
partial z or zed okay i just learned
that
americans pronounce zed as z
because it rhymes in the abcs a b c d e
f g
blah blah blah rhymes with z not zed
everyone else in the world calls it z
so this is the del or the nabla
operator and another way to write it
is as a vector
and then we can take the dot product or
the cross product of that vector
with other vectors so this could also be
written
equally as del equals
the partial partial x partial partial y
partial partial z or z
vector and if i
took this and dotted it with another
vector it would take partial partial x
of that first component plus partial
partial y of that second component plus
partial partial z
of that third component this can be
treated like a vector
and if you like this i hat kind of i
hat j hat and k hat just refer
to the first second and third components
of my vector
just like if i had a vector v
and i called it a b and c
that would be the same as a
in the i direction b in the j direction
and c in the k direction and i could
draw this
in uh you know coordinates in my
eye j
k coordinates i could draw this vector
as i take
a steps in the i direction b steps in
the j direction
and k step or c steps in the k direction
and that would determine my vector
v okay so i just want to just demystify
anything here
if you have an i j and k out front you
can write it as a sum like this in these
unit vector directions
you can write it as a column vector like
this where it's assumed that the first
component is in the x or i direction
the second component is in the y or j
direction
and the third components in the z z or k
direction
just like any other normal vector you
would ever write totally fine
okay
good and this grad
operator so so del or nabla sometimes
this is also called grad
maybe i'll put it up there this is also
the gradient or the grad operator
it is a linear operator and i'll tell
you
kind of how to compute the grad the div
and the curl in a minute
so i don't know what what the history of
dell versus nabla is
um yeah
nabla the homie uh funky homo sapien
uh it would sound a little weird or like
nabla tron 3030.
so okay let's look at these operators so
the gradient operator
maybe i'll switch colors here so the
grad
operator
essentially takes a scalar
field f and it turns it into a vector
field
okay so it takes a scalar f and it
returns a vector field
and it does it in the following way so
if i have
grad of f and little
f is uh let's say f
is a function of x and y and z or z okay
then grad of f is just partial
f partial x partial f
partial y partial f partial
z in a vector and for every point in
space there will be a
literally a vector direction with these
partial derivatives
determining that vector okay that's what
the gradient does
is it computes the rate of change of f
in the x direction y direction and z
direction
good and we already showed uh that you
can
think of this as like the gradient of a
temperature distribution it will tell
you in what direction
the temperature is rising the fastest
that's what the gradient of the
temperature would do
it would give you a vector direction at
every point of how that
temperature is increasing the fastest
along what direction
the divergence and i'm just going to
alternate colors so it's easy to see
the divergence takes a
vector f let's call this vector
f and it returns a scalar
field so it's kind of the almost exact
opposite
so if i take the um
the divergence it's literally defined as
the
dot product of my del operator my noble
operator
with my vector valued f
function and we assume that this vector
f has
three components f1 in the i direction
f2 in the j direction
and f3 in the k direction and all of
those f's are functions
so this would equal maybe i'll write it
up here so vector
f is literally uh
[Music]
f1 in the i direction plus f2 in the j
direction
plus f3 in the k direction
where each of these f's is a function of
x y and z
in three dimensions then this divergence
is going to be partial okay i'll write
it out because it's going to get ugly
it's partial partial x partial partial y
partial partial z that's del
dotted with f1 f2
f3 okay that's what del
dot f is it's literally taking this
operator
and dotting it with my function f
and so we know how to take the dot
product this is easy it's just the
partial of f1 with respect to x
it's partial f1 partial x
plus partial f2
partial y plus partial f3
partial z okay pretty simple
it's just a sum and now because we've
sum this up this is just a scalar
function
of x y and z so it took my vector field
and i returned a scalar field
and specifically it's going to compute
how much my
vector field is kind of instantaneously
or locally
expanding outward or contracting inward
so this divergence is going to be
greater than zero if my vector field is
kind of
sourcing out blowing stuff away from a
point
and it's going to be negative if it's
pulling stuff in or kind of attracting
stuff in into the vector field
and a divergence free vector field a
vector field where this is equal to zero
is called incompressible and it
literally means
incompressible in a fluid dynamic sense
okay the last one i want to show you is
the curl
and the curl is also kind of cool so the
curl
takes a vector f
and it returns a vector
field okay so all of these are a little
different the grad takes a scalar and
returns a vector
the div takes a vector and returns a
scalar and the curl takes a vector and
returns a vector
same f as before and literally the curl
is just nabla or del
cross product with my f function
okay now kind of a mess
i don't really want to do this but i'm
going to uh remember how to take the
cross product
it's pretty easy you take literally the
determinant of a matrix where you have
the i
j k directions
and then you have the vector
representation of del here which is
partial partial
x partial partial y
partial partial z and then the vector
representation of
f1 f2 f3 and you literally just compute
its determinant and it's not that bad
i'll write it out
in the i direction you have i
times partial f3
partial y minus partial f
2 partial z minus
in the j direction you have partial
f 3 partial x
x uh minus partial f1
partial z and then plus in the k
direction
you have i guess partial f
2 partial x minus partial
f 1 partial y
so again you can tell that this is a
vector field because it has an
i a j and a k component and the curl
roughly speaking maybe i'll draw a
picture for the divergence the
divergence of course measures
how much stuff is kind of sourcing out
from a point the curl is going to
measure how much stuff is kind of
swirling around in a circle it measures
kind of the
circulation around a point like this
okay
so a positive curl means we're rotating
around positive divergence means we're
kind of expanding out
and the gradient of course measures if i
have like a temperature distribution
from uh hotter to colder
it's going to give me directions where i
maximally go from hot from cold to hot
okay so really really simple this is
like the alphabet
uh this is the these are the building
blocks of vector calculus
it's all based on taking the derivatives
of things and measuring rates of change
remember we love calculus because we can
measure how things change in space and
in time
that's how we think about differential
equations that's how we think about
partial differential equations
is how things change in space and in
time
these are the building blocks that we're
going to use to quantify
things like conservation laws to derive
these partial differential equations
so in the next few lectures i'm going to
go into great detail
we're going to zoom into the gradient
operator and get physical intuition for
what this means
and how to compute it same thing with
divergence same thing with curl
and then we're going to start deriving
our vector calculus
kind of integral formulas like gauss's
divergence theorem
and stokes's theorem how these behave
under integrals
really cool stuff and especially when i
learned it there was no motivation for
why we were learning it we just had math
on a board
you are learning this specifically so
that you can
translate physics the language of the
universe into math
the language of differential equations
all right more to come thank you